[Music]
you
hello in the last lecture we looked at
what is perception
and we also looked at the classical
approach to perception in addition we
went ahead and saw the gestalt approach
to perception the organization principle
of the gas style and the law of plants
and the limitations of the gestalt
approach now perception which is making
meaning of visual stimuli is believed to
be a two-part process in terms of the
human brain
perception happens through something
called a bottom-up process and something
called a top-down process the bottom-up
process
is a data-driven process
and
it moves from top to bottom so if I
consider a triangle representing how the
process of perception really work moving
from general to specific is basically
what turbulent processes are most opt-in
processes bank upon may 6th immunise
properties add up these ways to make
these stimulus properties and come up
with a meaningful percept a meaningful
interpretation in contrast the top-down
processes are generally motivation
driven processes or Theory driven
processes what it means is coming from
specific to general most perception
require the top-down process and the
bottom-up process and so the next
particular thing that we are going to
understand in this lecture is the
bottom-up process and the top-down
process think what really happens when
you see a tree like this the process of
perception of visualizing this tree of
making meaning of this tree starts by
the creation of a proximal stimulus from
the distal stimulus by the eye the lens
of the eye projects this proximal
stimulus which is the inverted image of
the tree the inverted image of the
lights falling from the tree on to the
retina which then depending on the
intensity and the type of illumination
the type of electrical current that is
generated by the first the the proximal
stimulus sends this information on to
the occipital lobe the occipital lobe
then integrates various kinds of
information which is sent on by the
retina it's probably right time to
introduce that the retina does not only
passively transmits the intensity of
light waves which are falling onto it it
transmits several other information
about the distal stimulus onto the
occipital lobe for example some
information regarding the motion of
objects information regarding the
contours which divide the background and
the foreground and several other basic
information in terms of the color in
terms of the texture are transmitted by
the retina itself these informations are
then taken up by the occipital areas are
the visual processing areas now this
process which starts with light falling
off the tree being reflected on to the
lens and the retina and then there is
not passing up specific bits of
information onto the occipital lobe or
the occipital visual processing areas is
called the bottom-up process this
percept which is formed this
interpretation which is formed from the
primary inputs from the retina is then
compared with
pre-stored notions or pre-stored
representations into the brain and then
a meaningful interpretation a meaningful
idea is made about the particular object
in the environment in this case the idea
that this is the tree composed of two
parts the bottom-up process will include
those processes are those events in
through which the greens color the brown
color of the trunk the green color the
leaf the shape size of the tree the
texture of where the tree is standing
how far it is from some other object in
in the visual field these kind of
informations which leaders are the kind
of structure of the leave the idea that
it has a leaf and the idea that it is it
has a certain length and it is green in
color the bark is brown in color it has
roots
it has fruits these kind of information
which leads us to identify a particular
visual stimulus as a tree is the the
bottom-up process whereas taking all
these information to get this percept
together and comprising them to approach
the type of a tree to the idea of a tree
which is stored into the long-term
memory is the top-down process basically
most perceptual processes or most
perceptual events require the
integration of both the top-down and the
bottom-up process so let's start with
understanding what are the bottom of
processes in perception and looking at
some of the bottom-up processes in
perception which are used for
understanding the perceptual process the
bot the term bottom-up process or
data-driven process essentially means
perceiver starts the punt first person
who's perceiving the brain which is
perceiving the
image starts with bits and pieces of
information of the object in the
environment integrating them together to
form in a percept as I was explaining if
you're looking at a tree the idea that
green leaves are their ground
trunk is their roots are there flowers
are there it is of certain height it is
of turtle texture all this information
which is passed on from the retina onto
the occipital visual processing area is
what is the bottom-up process so
basically in this case in this
particular image I have brought an image
I have got an image which will explain
to you or which will try and explain to
you what is the how do we interpret the
meaning of this particular image through
a bottom-up and top-down process so
looking at this particular thing this
particular image what do you see most
people think of this as a corridor of a
kettle of old building or of a European
building or some kind of a corridor out
there the idea that this is a corridor
can be generated by both the top-down
and the bottom-up process from for the
bottom-up process what would happen is
you would see into this picture and
based on the kind of shading based on
the kind of light that is have that it
is having based on the kind of
architecture that it has the kind of
curves that it has the kind of our
architecture the kind of bricks that are
making this the diverging lines inside
this this image the diverging messages
inside there all these information basic
information the kind of steps that you
see the kind of arches that you see
these and and the Lighting's the pattern
the shading the color all these
integrate together to give you the idea
that this isn't hall and this process of
using these information from the visual
field to tell you that this is in Hall
is what is the bottom-up process in
contrast
it the top-down process we'll look at
this particular picture and compare it
with something that you have seen before
and we'll try to match up so if you have
ever been into a hall like this before
or if you have been to a cat riddle
before which has similar interpretations
or which were similarly interpreted or
which was seen similar to it or how
close that image which is in your mind
that representation of a holiday is in
your mind how close that fits to this
that gives rise to or that if if you're
using that to interpret that this is a
corridor of a cat riddle if you're using
that particular image or if you're using
that approach to to make giving meaning
to this image that is called the
top-down process so this picture through
a bottom-up process is basically coming
up from facts like the depth the figure
the ground in texture semicircular arch
a semicircular blocks doors and so on
and so forth now how do we understand
the bottom-up process an easier way to
understand the bottom-up process is that
bottom-up processes for both most
bottom-up processes as you move along
the chain as processes move along from
lower dimension to the higher dimension
there is no possibility of correction so
in most bottom-up processes as you move
higher along the dimension as you move
up higher along the processes there is
chances of Corrections are very low now
how do we visualize a bottom-up process
think of a class in which the person
who's sitting on the last bench is given
the task of writing a word anybody
wishes and then the next person to him
writes adds up another word our job here
is to interpret or basically make a
story of what students write onto it and
so the person next to the person who
wrote the word first writes another word
and this way this keep from what he will
soon see that the person at the front of
the class has
not much option what he has to do is he
has to look at whatever has been written
before and based on that make an
interpretation whatever processes are
like that basic stimuli or first
processes in are the first inputs are
taken in and from there how inputs are
made or higher configurations are made
but it is not possible to go back to the
basic inputs from which higher inputs
are made
no that's how we visualize the bottom-up
process also most bottom-up process are
automatic in nature as they don't
require some kind of control by the mind
they don't require some kind of
cognitive control so they are very
automatic process as you see something
the brain interprets the eye retina of
the eye basically breaks the information
which is coming into its similar path in
terms shading color and so on and so
forth interprets this takes in this and
sends it to the occipital visual area
for processing also these are very
reflexive processes what am i processors
are generally a reflexive process now
there are three or four bottom-up
processes that we will discuss in this
particular lecture the first is called
the template matching process it's a
very simple process and what it says
there are pre-configured template into
the brain and what really the bottom-up
process really does is it takes in
information from the visual world
integrates them together and compares
them across this template with this
template and when a match is recognized
an interpretation a correct
interpretation is done when a match is
not there another template is looked to
a match is made and so on and so forth
now think of templates as tencel's these
stencils in general use most tencel's
are used to make figures or to make
words or to make events which are
equivalent to the census in template
matching model or according to a
template matching matching model a
reverse of what the census does happen
so we have a fixed stencil into the
brain a fixed idea into the brain and
whatever the eye or whatever the visual
system is sending whatever information
it is sending into the brain it is taken
in and compared to preconceived stencils
out there as the information matches a
stencil
it is recognized a percept test form and
it is recognized as as it is and this is
called pattern recognition but if a
match is not found a next stencil looked
into and so a large number of comparison
has to be done also think of template
matching or understanding template
matching in terms of checks
now all of you would have seen what a
check looks like
so most checks have a certain area where
person can write his name and amounts
and then he has a signature area and
then below you see certain numbers what
is the use of these numbers these
numbers are generally used by check
sorting machines these checks slotting
machines which are installed in
different banks and what these banks
actually do is that based on various
numbers and letters it then forwards a
check to a particular branch it's a very
simple interpretation of what the
template matching model does so banks
otters or bank cheques otters are
equivalent to a template matching scheme
in which several templates are there
with the blank sorting machine and what
this machine does based on which numbers
and letters you have on the cheque it
will pass your cheque along to a
particular bank it's a very
comprehensive model and the main
proposal of this model there are prefix
templates into the brain and incoming
information from the eye is made into a
percept and a template it's matched to
preconceived templates into into the
brain and if there is a match and
interpret
is a minute if it's not a second
abilities looked about and so on and so
forth now there are several obvious
limitations of the template matching
model what are the first template
matching model limitation is the
requirement of a huge number of
templates now by its the design itself
the template matching model requires
that we have to have a huge number of
templates into the brain
now since the brain capacity the idea
that the brain has a fixed capacity and
it cannot have a large number of
templates so this model lacks a
particular feature lacks a particular
gain over other models also then a new
template or when a new image or new
object comes into perception in the
perceptual field how does the template
matching model account for that think of
Addison in this way the phone industry
started with button phones and then came
in the first resistive touchscreens and
the capacity touch screens no matter we
move from the button phones to the
resistive touch screen or the capacitive
touch screen phones people didn't have
any difficulty at all the bar kinda
phone with the buttons had a particular
mental template this is what is supposed
to do but then when people migrated to
capacitive touchscreen or touchscreen
phones they didn't have too much
difficulty into identifying touch screen
phones or the functions of the touch
screens corn which means that the
template of the button phone got
transferred or somehow accommodated the
new template of the capacitive phone or
it extended yourself to the capacitive
phone now how does that happen that's
not that's not explained by the template
matching model so it doesn't say that if
a new model comes in or if a new form of
object comes in which is I'll be
different from the template how do you
account for that also another
interesting thing or limitation of the
template matching modulus handwriting's
now a lot of people recognize a lot of
symbols as meaning the same
thing so how does the template mapping
model actually account for that on your
left on the slide you see a text return
and so this text has been very nicely
written in all capitals and it is very
easy to read and most people are able to
read it on the left you see a very bad
handwriting tell me this is it difficult
to read the text on your right it's not
most images or most letters are
preferably out there and it makes
meaning to you but template matching
model says that fixed templates are
available to the brain so if a is
written in this way
any deviation of a into like this will
not be matched and will be an outlier or
will be not perceived by the brain as we
can see handwriting's whereas as you see
here this day and this a here this a
here and this oh here and this F here
they don't match to the general way of
how f AE NC should be written but still
we are able to read this which basically
means that the existence of fixed
templates is something which is a far
off cry which is not true and so to
basically fill in the gap which was made
by the template matching model to
counter the limitations of the template
matching model as we saw in the study of
cognition that several methods are used
for studying cognition because one
method we have if one method of the
limitation a second method goes ahead
and plugs this limitation or basically
proposes something which accounts for
this limitation and so a better idea of
how of how a cognitive process really
works or how mentally means a process
that gives us a great idea
and so to plug in through this
limitations to account for these
limitations or the template matching
model a new model which was called the
feature analysis model was proposed now
what is the feature analysis model
feature analysis model says that when
exception happens when we perceive
things from the visual environment we
look for units basic units which are
called features we look for features
certain features on to proximal stimulus
which which is coming which is being
inputted true from the retina onto the
visual visual processing area so then
when looking for when looking at a
stimuli looking at a complex environment
or stimuli we generally do not perceive
the stimuli at as a whole but we break
the stimuli into its several part into
stimulus into its different features and
we look at these features perceive these
features integrated back and that is how
we go ahead and recognize a particular
particular object when I enter my
classroom how do I make this idea or how
do I perceive this classroom the idea of
a classroom or the perception of this is
a classroom is made by several features
of the classroom for example there is a
door there is a certain kind of edges
and angles which suggest which is a door
or there is blackboards and certain
ideas about what features a blackboard
should have what is the background what
is the foreground and that kind of a
thing is there so when perceiving
something or when looking at and any
environment finding out the basic
features or breaking a hole or breaking
a hole in visual environment it's too
intense different features helps us in
identifying an object much successfully
and much faster than gobbling up on or
then interpreting the whole of the
object as a whole there are several
support which is out there for the
feature analysis model for example the
idea that while perceiving something the
first step in perception is identifying
pictures starts by works on frogs on
retina frogs and so what scientists what
researchers did was they was they
implanted mic
electrodes into the retina of these
frogs and they found out that these
micro electrodes they responded
according to how the retinal cells
responded and so on where they found out
that there are certain specialized cells
onto the retina which goes ahead and
responds in certain ways in in different
ways for example to cells or to groups
of retinal detectors have been found one
is called the edge detector the other is
called the bug detector now the edge
detector is that group of cells in the
retina which become active or which fire
more when a frog retina or a when a frog
actually sees or forms a border between
dark and light area and this this group
of cells are called
the edge detectors so within the retina
itself they're a group of cells which
actually respond to the visual
environment to the input from the visual
environment and separate them into its
different features and so one of the
features of any percept is the contours
or the edges of where the figure in the
background is banking up to what what
the gestalt is said the first step or
the first process in any perception is
figure background effect and so this
particular experiment gave ideas that in
the retina itself there are group of
cells which actually make you
distinguish between the edges the light
and dark find the four edges
similarly retinal cells in France have
also been known to identify movements so
if there is a movement these retinal
cells actually go ahead and respond more
vibrantly more actively than other cells
and these are called the bug detectors
as you can see when when we actually see
this woman this picture of a woman here
who this is what the retinal image is if
you look into it this is how the retina
responds to and this is been captured
from a human eye through micro
electrodes and what what you actually
see is we don't see colors we just see
this kind of an interpretation this kind
of black and white contours in
to it similarly bug detectors have been
found so when you see somebody running
the bug detector which is there in also
in the human eye it responds something
like this as you can see it actually
goes ahead and responds in this way it
is responding to the motion of this
person whereas in this case it is
responding to the edge detectors are
responding to the edges the differences
between what the figure background would
be or what are the contours which
basically makes this this woman there so
this is basically the direct output from
edge detector and a bug detector into
the human eye and into the human eye and
what does this really mean it means that
at the level of the eye itself the
features are separated out now what
other basic idea
or what are the basic support which was
which was provided to the feature and
Isis model was by it
someone called living Bateman look at
the image that I am drawing
what does this image look like and so
most of you will be able to tell me it
is some kind of an cart with wheels into
it and and so these are the wheels this
is the body of the cart and this is a
handle for pushing it and so on and so
forth so basically this image that I
have done is basically an inconclusive
image it doesn't make any conclusion
doesn't fit into any template
pre-existing template but even when this
image makes no meaning most people or
people like the viewers that I have are
able to make at least some features
extract some features out of it for
example this is a cart it has real so
bases which basically means that it can
move it has a handle which can make it
move and then it has some kind of nose I
don't know why it is that is the kind of
things basic support by Biderman was
provided that even if an image an
inconclusive image like this was
presented to people people were able to
identify this and this provides support
the fact that people respond to features
and these features are what gives rise
to two interpretations to the bottom-up
process of how perception really takes
place now it
Biderman propose the conceptualization
or something called jion's and what
Biderman says that these jion's are
something called geometric ions so
bitumen gives the idea or suggests the
idea that unlike the ions in chemistry
there are something called geometrical
ions or some basic shapes which are
available and according to bitumen there
are 36 basic shapes which are available
in in the visual field and most
perceptions that we have are actually
interpretations of these 36
basic shapes so that's what's a what's
our vitamin says and he says that any
kind of interpretation or any kind of
change in perception can occur by
changing the arrangement of these jion's
so these are the beta means jion's if
you look into it this is the shape of a
Q this is a wedge pyramid cylinder
barrel expanded handle handle cylinder
cone arch these are some of I'm showing
you some of it but there are different
jion's available and what Biderman says
these are the basic Gian these are the
primary giannis which are required
geometrical lines which are required and
if you look into this most visual field
or most interpretations most perception
that we have is actually a combination
of these jion's and to say that these
jion's if you change a Gian you can
change the meaning of an object what do
I mean by that let's look at this so
this is the rectangular Gian this is the
semicircular Gian so when I look into it
right now the rectangular Gian and the
semicircular jiron it looks like income
but as soon as I change the arrangement
of this jion's I put this here and then
this cups now become a basket or a bag
and this is what the diamond says all I
need to do is change this Gian from here
to here to move this position argument
of Gian and then you start seeing these
two things together and that's what
bitumen says so as as you interpret it's
basically features that make you make a
perception and bottom-up processes
generally use the feature analysis model
for making any kind of interpretations
now beethoven's can say that these 36
jion's are necessary for forming all
basic shapes into the world he analogues
this into the idea or he contrasts this
into an idea of sound perception and he
says that there are a compare
his theory of 36 jion's with the 44
basic fundamental so as you would know
that there are 46 44 different phonemes
and these phonemes the basic sound
structure will study phonemes into the
in the chapter on sounds on and so there
will will study what fun amazed and but
right now what the idea here is that
this 444 basic sounds they combined
together they get together to give all
the English songs which are out there
and so what what Bitterman says is that
this idea of looking at these forty-four
phonemes and making all the sound is
similar to his idea of having 36 jion's
making all the shapes which are out
there and he says that if you interpret
a phoneme differently to phonemes
differently a different sound would be
interviewed be produced for example the
da and tough on you are most confused
whereas the da in Saffron you are less
confused and this is one of the basic
one of the basic tenants of the or
support of of this model of feature
analysis model of perception or top-down
processing so Biderman
shows us of a demand shows us this
particular this particular thing and he
says that when we see this particular
image most of us are at least able to
tell us that this looks like clop the
reason why this looks like a wrist watch
or a clock is because it has mechanical
parts which tends to move has a strap
and so on and so forth although we all
know that this is not a watch and this
is no no idea of a watch now support
from Elna gives us 1969 theory of
perception of perception of similar
letters also support the idea of the
feature analysis model now what
I found out they found out that items
are worse letters or words which have
similar shapes which has similar
features are confused more than words
which are different shapes and so what
Gibson said is that it is easy to
confuse between visual inputs of G and C
then to confuse between G and F the
reason being that G and C both have a
circular G on which which which is
attached to another small G on which is
there but if we look into G and C they
the circular G on is not there here we
have a circular G on where we have some
other kind of a G on and as the reason
how how these confusions occur so
confusions occur because G and C smalls
they share the same features or with
each other another support for this
feature analysis model comes from the
work of nicer who says that in a visual
search task
so what nicer did was he gave a visual
search task to his subjects and what was
the visual start starts the visual
search task was easy
he had letters like this
written and within these letters of
having a semi-circle
he hid a letter with straight angles so
as you can see there are gcq and
something like this where and on the
other hand he had letters like
like this now when he showed these two
displays two subjects he found out that
finding a Z in this case was easy
whereas in this case what it was
difficult why was that because in this
case Z was very distinct that has
features which are very is distinct from
all other letters in this percept
whereas in this case what really happens
is that Z says some of the basic
features with all other letter Z a TA
tkl and so it is very difficult for for
somebody to quickly identify Z into this
this particular visual input the reason
being that features are important to
perception he says that the more closely
two items share a feature the more
difficult it will be for us to separate
but the more distinct features are the
easier it is for us to to understand the
percept and what this all combines to to
make interpretation is that features are
important for bottom-up processing a
major major idea in whatever processing
is that features make a person
another interesting model or another
interesting study that we look into in
the feature analysis model is called the
Selfridge spend ammonium model what is
the Sailfish pendemonium model is a very
interesting model to look at self it's
pendemonium model will again discuss it
in another chap another chapter in
another coming chapter in this course
now what self is smarter model actually
tells is how does perception of letters
happen for example there is a letter a
and there is a letter B and there is a
letter error how does the visual system
perceive this now prior to this I
explained to you how the I have
specialized regions which can the retina
has specialized regions which can
process information regarding lines
angles curved edges and so on and so
forth and this information
is passed along to the brain the visual
processing areas of the brain which
takes this information and creates the
percept or creates the perception now
how are these letters perceive
now what pendemonium model of self it
says is that the perception of these
letters for example a starts by there
are several demons he calls them demons
and I call them sub processes which are
involved in the perception of a so if I
have to perceive the letter a it starts
at a very basic level
now since whatever process starts at
very basic levels or the first inputs
that I get from the eye is that a when
an a is displayed in front of you you
have something like this arched line you
have another arch line and you have a
line like this
now the basic demons actually read this
kind of input and they forward this
input into the letter daemon which will
then combine this into the different
interpretations for example to arch line
and a single line can mean three things
in the English language I can mean an a
I can mean a we although the we will not
have this between thing and I will have
a hatch now the thing is whether this is
a V or edge the interpretation of that
takes place through this kind of a
bottom-up process at the level in the
first level I have the line in edge
demand which will then which will
provide an input to the letter demand
not the problem with selfish model is
the letter demand cannot ask back or
cannot call back the edge daemon for
asking any questions also these demons
director demand or the curve demon or
the the demons which interpret land
lines and angles these demons keep on
shouting so there will be several
dementia will be demand of a straight
line where you have a different demon of
a slightly curved line on this side a
line and so on and so forth so those
demons which actually process this input
when when I show an a now the demon this
Damon is the one which is excited and so
it will shout the most and all other
Damon will shout the least will not
shout at all and so input from this is
basically taken in and fed into a letter
processor now the letter processor will
take the idea we'll get the idea that
there are two lines one which is slanted
to the left the other to the light and
run a straight line in between that is
what is that is what the information is
coming from the I if we look into this
combine this to basically produce three
inputs three things can happen with
these lines three different
english-language letters can happen
either we have a a we have a V or we
have an H and there is a sec and another
demand the highest demand which is out
there which will then look at compare
this with pattern recognitions with
patterns which have been stored in the
brain previously and say that a is the
only percept and F and H are not now
this kind of model selfish model is very
close to the connectivist model which we
saw in the first classes or in the first
lecture
throughout this series where will we
looked at how this connectivist model
really works we'll come back to the
connectivist model a little later into
the chapter of language and into the
chapter of memory so this is how the
model really works when image a is
presented there is an image diamond
which will first start shouting because
this is an image that is there and then
from later on then we have feature
diamond the feature diamond is there are
two lines and those these feature
diamonds will start sorting then there
are cognitive demands will interpret
what this is all about
then there are word demands and then
there is a decision lemon which is the
highest demand which says that this is
an a and not not and so on and so forth
good example is to look at it this is
the B image demand if you look here that
then these are several other diamonds
which represents various lines which are
there and so those lines those diamonds
which represent the features of an B
will shout the most and which do not
represent features of B will not shout
and then there are angled amends so we
have the image demand dang
think of the demon as a process of how
the processing takes place so how does
the processing takes place first we
divide B into a line like this into a
line like this into a line like this and
then combination of this so that is what
it is and this is how first the image
diamond excise then the line Domenic's
i'ts then the angle diamonds excites and
then the pattern diamonds because we
could also mean it is closer to R it is
also closer to B it is also closer to P
so these are the pattern diamonds which
are there where because these are all
the possibilities with this this and
this into being and then there is a
disease and MN which then compares this
this this and this and says that the
image that I have the input that I have
is the closest match with me so this is
how the selfridge model really works
there are several diamonds and these
diamonds are the inputs which you get
from the retina so this kind of a model
has been designed by Selfridge and it's
it's provides another greater support to
the feature analysis model that when we
perceive something it is the feature
that is important the feature analysis
model suffers from some very basic
shortcomings one of the first thing is
that there is no good definition of what
a feature is and what is to be expected
so the idea of what a feature should
have what is a feature should not have
is not very explicit and so once a
definition of what a feature should and
should not have is not it is not out
there we do not know what a feature what
should be a feature and how these
features are identified another problem
is there are different sets of features
for different objects and how does the
perceiver know which ones to use to
perceive an object for example for for
different objects we have different
different set of keys for a face we can
look into the eye and define a face we
can look at the nose and define a face
we can look at other features of the
face for the part of the face and define
a face so which are the ones which are
the prominent and which are the one
features which is the most for example
some people define a face define a
person based on his eyes and some people
look at the cut off her face the kind of
hairs are somebody has and so all of
them are features of the face so which
is the one which is the most important
is really difficult and
it's it's one of the main limitations of
the feature nemesis model another
interesting model which adds up or which
has been discussed as a bottom up model
is the prototype model now the product
model is very similar to the template
model but then it is an improvement of
the template model what does it do the
protec model says that whenever an input
is given to us whenever an input is
given by the visual system to the visual
processing system this is compared to a
stored representation of information
into the brain and so what template
model loses on to the prototype model
gains on to that so so in instead of so
what the template model what the
prototype model says is that instead of
comparing the total visual image which
has been provided by the eye instead of
taking this and comparing 800% with
templates which have been stored in a
brain we do some kind of close proximity
matching what we do is how closely what
we try to find out is how closely this
fits on to a mental representation which
is out there so we do not look for
hundred percent matches we look at how
closely they fit the more closely a
particular image a particular visual
scene comes to a stored representation
the more chances of it being categorized
as that particular representation now
the basic feature of the brain the basic
desire of the brain is to categorize the
brain doesn't has a lot of free energy
so what does the brain generally do is
takes up any stimulus which has been
given to it any kind of input which has
been given to it and then categorizes
the first thing that it does is
categorizes makes meaning out of it the
quickly can categorize something and
makes meaning out of it the lesser it
work it is required to do so that is
what the job of the brain is and one of
the things that the prototype matching
model does is eases the the function of
the brain or
the task of the brain by making an
assumption that the input which is
coming from the visual system is matched
in in in terms of in terms of problem
similarities rather than in terms of
complete similarities so instead of
being as a whole pattern that must match
how closely and that is a prototype now
what is a prototype the idea is what
water prototype is prototype is
basically an abstraction which is
generated from several instances of
event or an object for example for
developing a prototype we need to
understand that a prototype is develop
from several interpretations or several
instances of a particular even let's
take a look at this all four of these
images are actually cars right this is a
car which is a highly developed car this
is a very basic car as small currents on
a school but all of them are car
now when I say car what comes to your
mind the idea that what a car should
have is the prototype idea of a
prototype of a car so when I say a car
the basic features that a car should
have is what is a prototype and if I
look at this forecast what is the
similarity that I find into it most cars
most cars tend to have four wheels so
the first feature is four wheels it
should be driven by an engine and so
these are all driven by an engine and so
no matter how difficult or how new a car
model I come up with my prototype of a
car will actually try to match it
closely with it try to match the new
model of a car which is out there it's
closely with it and the kind of
similarity the kind of closeness the
kind of close approximations the close
similarity is that the new model has
with my car will tell how close the new
model of a car is to my prototype of a
car so when making a prototype I look at
all the similarities in all instances of
this image and from there I create a
prototype for the example in this
case the prototype of a car my prototype
of a car or anybody's protector of a car
should be something a vehicle first of
all they should be able to transport you
from player plays a to B then it should
also be able it should also have four
wheels at least so most of them have
four wheels it should have a body where
you should be able to sit and a cover or
something as you see most of these
images have have that thing that
prototype now in addition to a prototype
is something called an exemplar and in
extension of the prototype in example
now exemplar is basically the best
prototype which is available so the dog
is dog which is available is most people
believe that it is the dog yes dog is
the the common home dog which is called
the Alsatian or the small dog which
keeps in Barking which most people tend
to have that is the dog yes dog it
should have a tail it should have a far
it should bark and that is what the idea
is and so this is how the dogs are
compared into so a non session is the
dog is dog which is available and so
that is an exemplar when I think about a
exemplar an exemplar is the best example
of a category of a prototype which is
out there and so the most classic car
for me would be the BMW because that car
has all the features are in in terms of
the Indian standard the most prototype
car of the prototype of a car would be a
Maruti Alto is the most prototype of a
car because it has all the features of a
car it gives you all the features
although it may not have some of the
highest versions but it is that is the
prototype of a car so generally
prototypes are abstractions which are
made these are mental representations
which are made from several instances of
a particular of a particular category of
a particular class of events according
to protocol mathematical model matching
model when a sensory device registers a
new stimulus the device compares it with
pre previously stored prototypes an
exact match is not required for as
closely a match of what you are seeing
is to the prototype the
easily the more closely the way the
visual input matches to the pro tonight
the more easily it is understood or most
easily I it is identified as belonging
to that particular class now the
question is where do these prototypes
actually come from where do we develop
this prototype and an elegant answer to
this comes from a work done by Posner
and key what poster and qu'il says that
the development of a prototype they
found out how does prototype how do
people develop prototype and they found
found out that prototype development is
an automatic process and that's how
prototype develops it is by mere
exposure so what was the experiment in
their experiment what they and what they
did was initially they created a nine
dot pattern like this which they called
up there which they called as the
prototype and then with that in the
first version or in the first instance
they created our nine dot pattern in the
second instance they took this pattern
and placed it in a grid with patterns
which are similar to this but
distortions of this pattern so they gave
this kind of input to subjects so first
subjects were called in initially before
the subjects were called in nine dot
pattern like this was created which was
the prototype later on subjects were
called in and they were shown the
various distortions of the prototype
with something which is closer to the
prototype and they were asked to
classify these distortions which were
there for example this is as you can see
it will form a triangle here it will
form a triangle this is kind of a
triangle I cannot draw it right here but
then this is how it should look like
forms like this and so dot patterns are
like this which closely resembles a
triangle but not a triangle later on so
various arrangement distort
chance of this prototype was done in a
third phase of the study several other
distortions of the nine dot pattern was
given to subjects which were new
distortions and people were asked to
classify or to basically group these new
distortions what really happened people
were able so within this third
experiment in this third experiment we
included the original prototype the
distortions
from the old distortions into it and
some new distortions what was found out
that the chances of identifying the
prototype which the subjects have not
seen was 85% and the identifying of
identifying of old arrangements
distortions of the original prototype
we're almost 87 percent whereas
classifying or identifying these new
distortions which were nowhere near the
distortions of the this kind of new
distortions which were there which were
never close to these distortions new
older distortions which are there was
only 65 percent now what is of interest
to us is this 85 percent so all those
subjects was not shown the prototype
figure at all they were able to identify
the prototype figure on their own
how does this happen this happens
because subjects when classifying
something they have create a mental
representation they create a mental
abstraction and these abstractions are
used for classifying things or taking
new things and classifying according to
these representations which are this and
this is how things really work so this
is how the prototypes really come from
so in the next class then we go ahead we
will start discussing about the top-down
process this is the another process
model so as in today's lecture we went
ahead and saw what are the bottom-up
process model those models which take in
data and
this the witch actually taking data and
this data build up accumulate together
to actually form the percept in the next
leg possible in the next lecture we'll
go ahead and discuss about the top-down
model those models which are theory
driven which a motivation driven which
help us in perception thank you
[Music]
you